et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
louis aliot bonjour louis aliot merci
beaucoup d'être avec vous je vous êtes
le maire rassemblement national de
perpignan il vous êtes avec nous de
payer votre ville de perpignan on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentait par
fabrice vce à redon du groupe ebra
bonjour fabrique bonjour henriod merci
new fabris
on va parler longuement des régionales
un bien sûr louis aliot mais d'abord un
mot sur la crise sanitaire et c'est
l'inquiétude autour du varions indien le
variant delta très présent dans les
landes où jean castex est rendu hier il
a annoncé un plan d'action renforcé
est ce que pour vous il faut aller plus
loin et renfort confiner les territoires
où le variant progresse écoutez ça va
être très difficile de reconfirmer est
de faire comprendre qu'il y a à nouveau
un danger après tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui autour de la vaccination
autour d'eux des gestes-barrières et je
vais dire des protocoles qui sont mis en
place dans les spectacles ou dans les
lieux de sport donc je pense qu'il faut
être encore prudent regarder très
attentivement ce qui se passe dans les
landes
mais évidemment tout le monde espère que
ça ne va pas dégénérer
parce que je pense que si notre pays
souffrirait énormément d'une autre forme
de privation de liberté au moment où
l'été va débuter hier
est-ce que ça va trop vite pour vous le
déconfinement actuelle vous savez je
crois que les pouvoirs publics
aujourd'hui on font face à une une
volonté manifeste de la population tout
simplement de vivre de sortir avec des
précautions évidemment mais la
vaccination doit aussi s'accélérer
et puis moi je regrette mais y est la
mise en place et la recherche de
traitements qui qu'on le veuille ou non
n'ont pas été suffisamment popularisé
parce que je le dis à votre antenne je
connais beaucoup de gens qui se sont
fait traiter dès qu'ils auraient eu le
coc vide à d'état des formes précoces et
qui n'ont pas eu de suite grave donc là
aussi pourrait arrêter l'hypocrisie
et pardon comme comme la chloroquine je
voulais dire
oui mais pas que l'ivermectine
l'azithromycine des antibiotiques tout
ce qui fait que l'on peut limiter leur
charge virale du virus pour empêcher les
formes graves et encore une fois
moi même j'ai été malade et je suis
témoin que ça fonctionne donc il faut
arrêter l'hypocrisie
alors je sais c'est votre avis et des
médicaments qui ne sont pas tous validés
par par l'union européenne et par les
agences de santé juste on le précise un
mot sur la vaccination le premier
ministre il lance un appel hier dans les
landes
ayez peur du virus n'ayez pas peur du
vaccin alors que le nombre de premières
doses faibli 200 milles par jour il ya
une décélération de la prise des
rendez-vous comment on convainc les
réfractaires de se faire vacciner
est-ce qu'il va falloir la rendre
obligatoire cette vaccination
non je ne pense pas qu'il faille la
rendre obligatoire en revanche on peut
faire plus en terme de communication
pour inciter les gens à y aller et je
pense que notamment celles et ceux qui
encore ne sont pas vaccinés à des âges
avancés on pourrait les inciter
fortement et y aller mais si vous mettez
une obligation c'est là que se poseront
les problèmes
je pense qu'on a un peu baissé la garde
parce que le déconfinement parce que la
chaleur les beaux jours alors qu'il faut
quand même à maintenir la pression nous
a permis perpignan on a des centres de
vaccination ouverts et on essaye de
communiquer pour que les gens continuent
à aller se faire vacciner
c'est notre seule chance en tout cas on
espère que c'est notre seule chance
parce que sinon nous irons à l'automne
vers une autre forme de deux contraintes
et très haut je suis très inquiet - de
l'avenir de notre vie sociale en général
par rapport à cet assaut virus et à la
manière dont on gère les conséquences de
ce virus quelques si vous inquiète mais
à lyon les gens en ont marre ils en ont
ras le bol voilà on leur a dit
fait c'est fait de ce barrière des
masques restez chez vous ils l'ont fait
après on leur a dit le virus et c'est la
panacée universelle ils ont fait une le
fond si demain on nous apprend que le
virus mais peut-être n'est pas aussi
efficace qu'il ya des variants que le
pardon le que le vaccin n'est pas aussi
efficace sur certains variants etc on va
encore inquiété et je peux vous dire que
les gens souffrent énormément pas
seulement économiquement mais
socialement humainement par là ça
devient très compliqué on voit bien
aujourd'hui dans les rues et un peu
partout qu'il ya des gens qui veulent
vivre et qui sont manifestement
aujourd'hui totalement déconnecté de du
sérieux qu'il faudrait encore avoir par
rapport à un certain nombre de
situations socialement justement nous y
allions vous nous parler ce matin on
dirait que pratiquement de la frontière
espagnole
les françaises et français qui veulent
aller en espagne comment se passe à
cette heure la fluidité la circulation
entre les deux pays
aujourd'hui la fluidité est plutôt est
plutôt correct
l'espagne a ouvert ses frontières et
avec les protocoles comme un peu partout
en europe
mais c'est vrai que plus on va aller
vers les vacances et plus ça risque
d'être compliqué sur les routes donc on
espère réellement que ce virus et que le
taux de positivité à s'abaisser pour
permettre à tout le monde de passer de
bonnes vacances dans une relative
tranquillité et une relative sérénité
il faut pas inquiéter outre mesure par
rapport à des à des poches comme cela
d'infection je pense évidemment aux
landes
mais encore une fois resté très très
vigilant et ne pas baisser la garde
je pense que c'est important on va
parler des régionales évidemment lui a
lieu est d'abord de cette abstention
abstention record et abstention aussi
des lectorats rassemblement national 73
% de vos électeurs ne se sont pas
déplacés dimanche selon ipsos est ce que
vous pensez vraiment pouvoir les faire
revenir aux urnes et comment écouter
d'abord depuis 20 ans et toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion qui sont fait prouve
que l'abstention nuit et a toujours nuit
au rassemblement national
j'écoutais encore ya pas très longtemps
le patronne de l'ifop des études de
l'ifop qui le confirmer c'est bien notre
électorat qui a refusé de se déplacer
qui ne s'est pas déplacé alors pourquoi
ça c'est à déterminer je pense que
toutes les raisons sont bonnes mais moi
je sais que nos équipes aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont engagés sur les
départementales ici à perpignan dans les
pyrénées orientales en frappant au porte
bien discute avec les électeurs et les
forme de lassitude puis de se dire que
deux week-ends d'affilée comme ça pour
aller voter pour quatre élections en
quatre tours et bien c'est un peu trop
il ya des gens qui ne vont plus voter au
premier tour
je l'avais déjà constaté moi en 2014 et
il ya des gens qui ne se déplace plus
qu'au second tour c'est pour cela que
j'ai dit que un électorat de deuxième
tour et que dans cet électorat de
deuxième tour il y à de gros bataillons
de votants en notre faveur et en faveur
des candidats soutenus par le m
c'est pour ça que je suis
raisonnablement optimiste pour dimanche
et la remobilisation de l'électorat
beaucoup beaucoup accusent marine le pen
d'avoir engueuler vos électeurs
abstentionnistes dimanche soir est
derrière dans son sillon sébastien chenu
aussi vous l'avez ressenti cette cette
forme d'un victimes nous pas du tout
vous savez les électeurs nous sommes des
électeurs nous faisons partie du peuple
français et nous sommes en droit de dire
aussi les choses que l'on pense car la
politique malheureusement aujourd'hui
c'est trop de communication est trop de
choses qui se ne se disent pas on est en
démocratie la démocratie c'est le vote
ne pas aller voter c'est maintenir le
système en place et il n'est pas normal
qu'en 75% des gens ne sont pas allés
voter
de leur dire votre responsabilité c'est
d'aller voter il ya tellement de pays au
monde qui n'ont pas le droit de vote qu'
on ne peut pas se payer le luxe de ne
pas aller voter
et donc c'est je pense de la pédagogique
de leur demander d'y aller et
quelquefois de leur dire voilà tout le
monde se plaint tout le monde manifeste
on en a marre du système on en a marre
de vaincre en a marre de ceci de cela il
n'y a qu'une seule manière d'exercer la
démocratie c'est le pluralisme politique
et c'est le vote pas d'autres formes
c'est le vote la démocratie parce que
tout le reste ce ne sont que des
aventures et on sait très bien que les
aventures peuvent porter sur des formes
graves de contestation et ça à titre
personnel et orl nous n'en voulons pas
alors vous vous expliquer sa part un
problème de conjoncturelle entre
guillemets 1,4 4,4 et sûrement de
semaine c'est trop et jean marie le pen
lui il a une autre explication vous
l'avez sans doute entendu hier il dit
que les chefs du rassemblement national
lors du premier tour de ces régionales
est due à la dé lepénisation du parti
qu'est ce que vous en dites
mais j'en dis que soit il a oublié soit
une
il ne pense qu'à lui à une espèce
d'égoïsme personnel parce que ça fait
vingt ans que ça dure il aurait dû s'en
apercevoir depuis 20 ans quand il était
à la tête du parti et que nous étions
victime de l'abstention c'était pourquoi
c'était parce que c'était lui qui
provoque l abstention voilà je pense qui
pour le coup il raconte n'importe quoi
ça fait ça fait parler dans les
rédactions et à la télévision
mais très honnêtement ça n'a aucune
importance auprès de nos concitoyens la
situation quand même vous interroge sur
la poursuite ou non de la normalisation
de votre parti politique à laquelle vous
avez vous même activement travaillé dans
votre précédent post à la à la tête du
parti
est-ce qu'il faut la poursuivre ou
revenir sur les fondamentaux plus
lepéniste pour reprendre le terme du
patron historique du parti
je sais très bien que la lepénisation ça
permettrait à beaucoup de journalistes
de nous permettre de nous taper dessus
mais la normalisation elle nous a permis
de doubler les votes avec marine le pen
depuis qu'elle a pris les rênes du parti
elle nous a permis aussi de gagner à
perpignan de gagner à fréjus à hénin
beaumont à béziers et donc il faut
arrêter de prendre conscience extremis
en que l'on va mobiliser l'électorat
c'est précisément en développant des
arguments un projet des profils à
rassemblant des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur du rassemblement national
comme thierry mariani en paca où jean
paul garraud ici en occitanie c'est
comme cela que nous arriverons à gagner
et pas se mettant dans un corner et en
essayant de faire j'allais dire plus
extrémiste que son voisin ça je n'y
crois absolument pas et faire cela c'est
le gage du maintien du système
c'est collaborer avec le système qui
éternellement considérera que nous
sommes le danger alors que on voit bien
quelle toile dire i
des examens dans le système aujourd'hui
louis aliot est ce que vous n'y êtes pas
vous dans le système si on n'y est pas
puisque tout le monde est contre nous
vous ne pouvez regarder cela que par
rapport aux autres
tout le monde est contre nous c'est donc
qu'il ya un système qui est contre nous
mais quand on gère les affaires
publiques comme ici à perpignan béziers
fréjus et autres les affaires sont bien
gérées et laisse concitoyens nous le
disent et votent pour nous tous nos
mères ont été réélus pratiquement au
premier tour c'est dire si la gestion
est efficace si les les valeurs sont
respectées
si la politique elle est autre chose que
ce qu'il y avait avant qu est ce qui se
passe dans nos mairies
c'est ce qui se passera demain dans
certaines régions et très certainement
ce qui sera passera de 1 en france
et justement continuer éternellement on
va on va parler des régions nathalie
thierry mariani a dû un peu le garrot
louis aliot mais en en 2015 vous étiez
en tête à l'issue du premier tour dans
six régions dimanche vous n'êtes en tête
que dans une région la région sud dont
on va parler à ce que ça a été une
claque mais c'est pas une claque c'est
une démobilisation de l'électorat y
encore une fois c'est une bataille
électorale c'est pas parceque de sueur
sur un tour il y à un échec dans
certaines régions que c'est une
catastrophe nationale la catastrophe et
les sous nos yeux c'est le chômage et
l'insécurité l'immigration massive le
communautarisme c'est ça la catastrophe
c'est ça qui est en train de tuer la
république et dans cette affaire-là nous
n'avons nous aucune responsabilité et
moi je m'adresse à l'électorat si vous
continuez à vis à voter pour les mêmes
ne vous
leigné pas vous aurez toujours la même
politique et que vous voyez la gauche
qui appelle à voter à droite la droite
qui appelle à voter à gauche des gens
qui se disaient autonomes et qu'ils
disaient à leurs électeurs mais vous
verrez au deuxième tour en semaine
tiendra parce que nous on ne peut
exister que c est qui se couchent
lamentablement comme en paca avec les
écologistes
mais tout ça c'est minable et je
comprends que les électeurs se soient
déçoit soir en désaffection de ce
système là c'est pour cela qu'il faut
changer
voilà changer de politique on ne peut
pas changer de politique si on ne change
pas les dirigeants qui la porte
et ça ce sera le grand débat non
seulement de ce second tour
mais le débat des élections
présidentielle et des élections
législatives à venir le retrait de la
gauche en paca justement est-ce que ça
être douchés vos espoirs de victoire
dans cette région bah non regardez les
enquêtes d'opinion est encore un sondage
aujourd'hui qui met les deux à 50 50 si
on faisait des additions monsieur
mariani serait scotché à 34%
et puis les autres ferait la course en
tête mais c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe moi j'ai vécu ça à perpignan
j'étais seul contre une candidate de
droite qui a bénéficié de tous les
soutiens de la gauche de l'extrême
gauche des écologistes et à la fin j'ai
gagné avec 53% des voix
c'est exactement de pareil en paca je
pense que thierry mariani l'emportera
dimanche parce que les électeurs de
gauche ne vont plus systématiquement
voté comme des moutons pour un candidat
dont on leur a dit qu'ils étaient nuls
pendant 6 ans sont pas foulés germain
sont pas suicidaires et donc je pense
que entre la démobilisation d'un certain
nombre d'électeurs et la remobilisation
de notre électorat nous aurons une bonne
surprise un pack à dimanche
un dernier mot sur cette région paca
puisque ce matin dans un entretien à
nice matin nicolas sarkozy sort de son
silence il apporte son soutien à renaud
muselier est ce que c'est un coup dur
quand même pour thierry mariani qui
était son ministre et dont nicolas
sarkozy pointe ce matin la trahison des
engagements
mais que pèse nicolas sarkozy qu qui est
arrivé troisième
dans sa propre couche course interne au
sein de l air voilà c'est un has been de
la politique il est ailleurs il fait
partie de l'ancien mur en deux et tout
ce qui peut dire aujourd'hui au bénéfice
de monsieur muselier de son ami estrosi
n'ont aucune importance et à la limite
je vais vous dire mieux plus des gens
comme ça parle plus il mobilise notre
lectorat et puis s'il ya des gens qui
ont voté pour nous dimanche on va parler
de la région occitanie jean paul garraud
votre candidat est très loin derrière
carole delga au premier tour il ya plus
qu'un point qui les sépare comment vous
expliquez ce score écoutez par tout
simplement encore une fois il ya un
électorat qui suis pas allé voter
uniquement l'abstention est ce que c'est
une erreur de quoi est-ce que c'était
mauvais profil jean paul garraud et non
quand vous avez une vague nationale
comme celle là ce n'est pas que jean
paul garraud vous voyez bien que c'est
nationale donc c'est pas jean paul
garraud qui est en cause c'est
aujourd'hui une prime aux sortants des
gens qui ne vont pas voter et j'allais
dire au système électoral qui est un peu
en difficulté
donc moi je suis pas très inquiet sur le
vote conjoncturelle et jean paul garraud
peut encore nettement progressé au
second tour surtout que madame delga
aujourd'hui à fermer la porte aux
écologistes et aux gens de la france est
soumise qu'elle a méprisé à en
n'intégrant pas dans ces listes parce
qu'elle veut gouverner seul vous savez
on est un cas particulier en occitane et
on a la seule présidente de région qui a
été condamné pour discrimination à
caractère politique c'est à dire que des
juges en première instance en appel en
cassation en ont prouvé qu'elles avaient
su créer des subventions de l'argent
public à une commune parce que cette
commune ne pensaient pas comme elle si
c'est ça la démocratie et bien l'avenir
je pense que nous aurons
le problème dans cette région c'est pour
cela que j'appelle les électeurs a bien
regardé dimanche quand ils vont voter
parce qu'ils ont affaire très
certainement à la pire présidente de
région en france est la pire au secteur
que nous ayons jamais eu
louis aliot vous évoquiez béziers à
plusieurs reprises pour cette interview
robert ménard votre collègue mr baiser
apparente et le rassemblement national
est un petit peu plus critique par
rapport à la stratégie du rassemblement
national sur ces régionales
départementales avec deux points
principalement la connexion du mouvement
aux préoccupations réelles quotidienne
des français et aussi l'ancrage
territorial des candidats qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez que c'est tout le
travail à faire de l'avenir de la
formation de s'implanter de s'ancrer
effectivement de localement de faire
vivre la démocratie locale vous
l'heureux événement robert ménard sur ce
constat mais marino si vous savez elle
rejoint ce constat et c'est pour cela
que tout notre effort doit porter sur
l'implantation locale et la formation de
nos cadres et de nos élus locaux
mais pour un parti comme le nôtre on
vienne de loin c'est long mais je suis
persuadé qu'avec beaucoup de travail et
de bonne volonté on arrivera pour les
échéances à venir à être tout à fait
j'allais dire en adéquation avec ce que
souhaitent nos électeurs et qu'on
répondra en partie à cette critique que
l'on peut entendre et qu'en tout cas moi
je comprends parfaitement
un mot sur les départementales dans
votre département des pyrénées
orientales louis aliot vous pensez être
en mesure vous de le faire basculer
votre département qui est aussi celui de
jean castex vous avez tendu la main
à des binômes de droite au lendemain du
premier tour est ce qu'il ya des
discussions entre des binômes l air et
des binômes rassemblement national donc
pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
discussion vous savez on est présent
dans 14 cantons sur 17 ans duels
notamment un certain nombre contre la
gauche et je pense que dimanche prochain
nous ferons notre entrée évidemment au
conseil départemental et même si une
petite vague à notre faveur nous
pourrons être soit majoritaire soit le
pôle majoritaire de la nouvelle majorité
départementale dont il n'y a pas de
discussion
mais tout se fera en toute transparence
et publiquement au troisième tour c'est
à dire au moment où il faudra élire les
exécutifs mais je créerai je vous
l'annonçais là aujourd'hui à la
télévision et je crains que monsieur
castex n'est déjà engagé les
négociations entre la droite et l'air du
département et la gauche socialo
communistes ça prouvera finalement la
collusion qui existe entre les uns et
les autres
vous avez dit regretter information est
exactement j'ai ouï-dire et en tout cas
avant même que le scrutin ait eu lieu je
sais que monsieur castex est intervenu
dans le choix des binômes notamment dlr
pour qu'à certains endroits il y aider
les représente a d'autres nam est pas et
au soutien d'un certain nombre de maires
dans certaines communes pour permettre
justement les arrangements un peu comme
un deuxième tour je suis pour qu'on soit
clair sur ce que vous dites sur le
troisième tour ça veut dire quoi que
vous pourriez faire alliance avec les
républicains au troisième tour pour
contrer la gauche
je pense que dans un cadre d'un contrat
de gestion et pour éviter que la gauche
continue à gérer ce département avec une
politique complètement folle et qui
d'ailleurs produit des résultats de
misère sociale absolue et bien
effectivement effectivement pardon peut
s'entendre
je pense qu'on n'est pas obligés de
s'embrasser vous faire de la politique
et qu'on peut discuter sur des idées sur
des projets et
sur un échéancier et moi évidemment avec
mes équipes nous sommes prêts à
travailler sur ce schéma là on va parler
du congrès du rassemblement national
louis aliot il aura lieu il aura lieu
dans dix jours à perpignan marie le pen
quittera la tête du parti pour se
consacrer à la présidentielle ce serait
un beau symbole pour vous de prendre la
présidence du parti dans votre ville à
écouter on a n'est pas là et ça ne se
fera pas à perpignan vous savez le
congrès il et il est bien organisée qui
a un vote interne des adhérentes qui est
déjà en cours la présidente sera marine
puisqu'elle est la candidate déclarée et
qu'elle sera élu lors de ce congrès et
il ya le l'élection du conseil national
qui est la naissance
louis aliot elle a déjà annoncé elle a
été nécessaire là dessus elle sera
candidate à la séquence n'a plus de
président du r n est simple vous voulez
être le président du rassemblement
national est ce que vous voulez lui
succéder ça ça elle le fera après le
congrès de perpignan et nous auront tout
loisir d'en discuter
aujourd'hui à l'heure où on se parle ce
n'est pas le sujet vous adorez originale
par oui vous en avez envie d'être
candidat mais il n'y a pas une histoire
de candidats c'est elle qui décidera
entre un certain nombre de possibilités
qu'elle a par rapport à l'organisation
qu'elle de qu'elle fera de ce n'est l'ex
de sa campagne présidentielle
donc je pense que les choses ne sont pas
tout à fait calées on verra bien si on
me le demande je le ferai à pouvait
plaisir si c'est mon ami jordan bardella
ici très bien que je serai absolument à
ses côtés pour mener
au sein du rassemblement national
j'allais dire une politique de
précisément d'unité et de préparation
des élections législatives moi vous
savez ça fait trente ans que je suis
dans la politique
j'ai toujours été un fidèle à des
convictions des idées et des hommes
ce qui malheureusement politique n'est
pas souvent le cas et je n'ai pas de
souci là-dessus
elle a quand même plusieurs candidats
sur la frange droite de l'échiquier
politique face à elle pour la
présidentielle vous pensez qu'elle est
toujours la bonne candidate pour la
présidentielle pour vous représenter
bah oui ça c'est une évidence vous savez
moi je regarde attentivement ce que
pensent les autres candidats sur sa
droite mais je ne suis pas impressionné
soit parce qu'ils disent soit parce
qu'il démontre
nous avons une solution pour vous non
c'est pas une solution voilà ce sera un
soutien je l'espère au second tour mais
c'est pas une solution
je pense que nous avons une jeune femme
d'expérience ce sera sa troisième
élection présidentielle et tout l'acquis
qu'elle a qu'elle a emmagasinée depuis
maintenant longtemps par rapport à cette
élection présidentielle la leadership
qui est le sien aujourd'hui dans les
intentions de vote comme dans notre
famille politique qui sont
incontestables en font la mieux placée
en tout cas moi je sais que la vie tout
mon soutien et qu'elle l'aura et qu'elle
aura encore pendant un petit moment
une dernière question très rapidement
louis aliot questions d'actualité qui
n'a rien à voir avec les régionales sur
la hongrie à une polémique actuellement
autour d'un projet de loi hongrois qui
vise à interdire la promotion de
l'homosexualité auprès des mineurs les
dirigeants européens le condamne
contraire aux valeurs de l'union
européen européenne des cils certains
demandent même à la hongrie de quitter
l'union européenne est ce que vous
dénoncez cette fois hongroise
écoutez je ne la connais pas et j'avoue
que j'étais la tête dans le guidon je ne
vais pas lui que je l'aurais lui je vous
raymond opinion mais s'il veut le virer
la hongrie de l'union européenne ça
prouve qu'on peut en sortir et que ça
choque pas une majorité en tous cas de
ceux qui la dirigent
donc je veux dit que c'est une
possibilité qui peut être demain sera
offerte à la france d'en sortir parce
que cette espèce de carcans idéologiques
qui notamment en matière d'économie or a
flingué notre agriculture notre
industrie et nos services publics
à un moment donné va falloir se poser la
question quand même du maintien de ce
système ou de la sortie de ce système
merci beaucoup merci louis aliot d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin depuis
affaires pignon regarde la une de vosges
matin fabrice trois coups pour une
reprise le retour du théâtre à la une de
vosges matin
[Musique]